así estarán estamos aquí en el park
güell en una de las 15 convocatorias y
por el momento había una tensa calma
pero parece que eso puede estallar en
cualquier momento los manifestantes hay
un centenar aproximadamente y por parte
de la policía de los antidisturbios
tenemos como varias decenas hasta hace
un rato la policía estaba detrás de la
comisaría que anoche fue incendiada pero
acaba de avanzar a primera línea y los
manifestantes están bastante enfadados
por todo lo que pasó ayer también hay
presencia de defensores de derechos
humanos y de mediadores de la alcaldía
que tratan de que no se vuelvan a
repetir los incidentes de ayer como
hemos dicho en el que acabó la comisaría
incendiada y donde también hubo disparos
de fuego real por parte de la policía
cabe destacar que la alcaldesa claudia
lópez había pedido a los manifestantes
que se retirasen a sus casas a las 7 de
la tarde pero ya son más de las 8 y aquí
continúa habiendo un gran número de
gente cabe destacar que el parc güell es
un barrio residencial de clase media
donde también hay fuerte presencia de
extranjeros teatros cafés y las imágenes
de ayer la verdad es que no suelen ser
habituales en este parque como observar
las medidas de seguridad luis y también
platícanos sobre la
acciones que han dejado al momento las
protestas de anoche como respondió la
alcaldía de bogotá el gobierno de iván
duque o la ciudadanía respecto al actuar
policial
si la verdad es que ha sido un día
intenso de declaraciones la alcaldesa a
claudia lópez ha estado visitando
distintos hospitales de la ciudad de
bogotá para visitar a los heridos y
también para dar acompañamiento
emocional a los familiares durante el
día que ha tenido varias declaraciones
de un ácido que no recuerda ni en los
años más duros del conflicto que hayan
habido 66 heridos por arma de fuego por
bala real también ha dicho que va a
hacer caso a las familiares y les ha
prometido una investigación alternativa
una investigación independiente por otro
lado también el gobierno le ha
contestado a claudia lópez que el
enemigo no es la policía sino que son
los vándalos además el presidente iván
duque ha lamentado las víctimas pero ha
dicho que los casos de fuego real son
individuales que no hay que frenar
hacerlo en la policía y también ha hecho
un fuerte despliegue de más policías
junto al ministro de defensa para
intentar que no se vuelvan a repetir los
hechos de la noche del miércoles
muchas gracias luis muñoz y mucho
cuidado nos mantendremos pendientes
contigo del desarrollo de esta noticia
en colombia